talking about machine learning for
algorithm design and ellen is from
stanford
oh thank you
okay um thank you
so um the title of this topic is machine
learning for algorithm design and um my
goal is to just give like a broad uh
overview of various ways in which
machine learning
is now being used for algorithm design
and um some of it will tie in pretty
directly with things that say annopam
was talking about this morning
so just to start off with some pretty
broad motivation
so an important property of those
algorithms that are typically used in
practice is broad applicability the
ability to solve problems across diverse
domains and i think one of the best
examples of this is integer programming
solvers
which are among the most popular tools
for solving combinatorial problems and
have tons of applications from routing
manufacturing scheduling planning
finance and many others
however these very broadly applicable
algorithms can often have unsatisfactory
default
out-of-the-box performance with slow run
times
poor solution qualities among other
downfalls
and um one of the main challenges in
using these types of very broadly
applicable algorithms is that they often
have a ton of tunable parameters so for
example integer programming solvers like
cplex and grobe come with
tons of parameters cplex has a 170 page
manual describing 172 different tunable
parameters
and tuning these parameters by hand is
just a notoriously slow tedious and
error-prone process but with a good
configuration they can be used to solve
very computationally challenging
problems
so this raises the question what's the
best configuration of my algorithms for
the particular application
and the best one for solving routing
problems that a shipping company has to
solve day after day it's probably not
particularly well suited for solving the
scheduling problems that an airline
faces
another example that i'm going to um
come to throughout i'm going to use as
an example throughout this talk
is sequence alignment where uh the goal
is to line up uh pairs of strings and
sequence alignment also has a ton of
applications from biology nlp many other
areas
so the input to a sequence alignment is
like a pair of sequences like these two
and the output is an alignment of those
sequences
and there are a lot of different
features of an alignment that we might
care about
uh for example the number of matching
characters the number of mismatched
characters
um the number of insertions and
deletions or indels for short where a
character is lined up with a gap
character
and the number of offline gaps which are
these consecutive sequences of gap
characters
and um
among many other features and so the
standard algorithm for
solving sequence alignment problems from
computational biology and other areas
is defined by say three tunable
parameters row one row two and row three
and it returns an alignment using
dynamic programming which maximizes the
subjective function
number of matches minus row one times
the number of mismatches minus row two
times the number of indels minus row
three times the number of gaps
so sometimes in sequence alignment we
can access some ground truth reference
alignment so for example this is
sometimes the case in computational
biology
but accessing these ground truth
alignments
is very computationally challenging that
you it requires extensive manual
alignments by some domain expert so we'd
rather just run that parameterized
algorithm from the previous slide
but this raises a question how do i tune
that algorithm's parameters how do i
know if i prefer indels to mismatches
and so on
and as bestfield at all wrote there's
considerable disagreement among
molecular biologists about the correct
choice of these sequence alignment
parameters
but a good alignment can make a really
big difference so here for example is
like a ground truth alignment of a pair
of protein sequences
here's an alignment by an algorithm with
poorly tuned parameters and in blue i've
indicated where the algorithm's output
lines up with the ground truth alignment
meanwhile here's an alignment by an
algorithm with well-tuned parameters and
you can see that the algorithm with
well-tuned parameters is able to recover
much more of the ground truth alignment
okay and one last example of very
broadly applicable algorithms
is clustering which have many diverse
applications from ecology biology and
network analysis
and so on and um in
this there are many different clustering
algorithms one might use to cluster your
data so for example here are five
different clustering algorithms that
i've used to cluster three small
clustering instances and you can see
that some of these algorithms do pretty
well in some of the instances and pretty
terribly on other instances
and so this raises the question when i
have a bunch of different algorithms
that i could use how do i select the
best algorithm for my application
well in practice we're often not solving
problems in isolation
in fact we often have a lot of data
about the particular application domain
in which we'll be using the algorithm
data that we could potentially harness
for the process of algorithm selection
so given a bunch of different algorithms
which one should i choose like in
clustering
um given an algorithm with a ton of
different tunable parameters how should
i configure that algorithm's parameters
and even more broadly in the context of
algorithm design
so just to give some examples
a shipping company will have access to
all of the routing problems it has to
solve day after day and although demand
changes daily
the structure of the problem really
doesn't change by that much you're still
routing over the same network structure
every day
a biology lab will have access to all of
the clustering problems it has to solve
on a week-to-week basis
and in airline will have access to all
of the scheduling problems it's had to
solve
over the course of like several years
so this idea of using machine learning
and data in the context of algorithm
design
has been studied pretty extensively over
the past two decades or so
especially from an applied perspective
and has led to breakthroughs in the
context of constraint satisfaction
programming
integer and linear programming
designing algorithms for economic
context or mechanism design
and computational biology among many
other areas and this is just a few of
the very early papers that thought about
using machine learning in these
algorithm design contexts
in contrast there's been surprisingly
little known about using machine
learning for algorithm designed in a
from a theoretical perspective
but this started to change maybe five
years ago or so and we really started to
see a surge of interest in theoretical
research on using machine learning for
algorithm design
some of this has included for example
research on algorithm configuration and
selection
starting with this itcs paper by tim
rufgarden and rishi gupta
as well as literature on algorithms with
predictions or learning augmented
algorithms
where
algorithms are endowed with some machine
learning hints about the input
distribution
so in the remainder of this talk
i'm going to give an overview of
three different ways in which machine
learning has been used for algorithm
design starting with algorithm
configuration
then i'm going to describe some research
on algorithms with predictions
and then a paper on learning to prune
the relevant regions of the search space
um and so this first section on
algorithm configuration
uh like i said was really started uh
by rishi and tim rufgarden and this rtcs
paper
i'm going to focus on a
stop 21 paper of myself nina balkan
dan de blasio travis sid carl kingsford
and thomas santolm and also refer you
all to a book chapter by nina balkin
which nicely synthesizes this area of
research
so first off uh let me give the general
model for what automated algorithm
configuration with using machine
learning and data would look like and
this has been kind of the general
paradigm stretching back to those early
papers i mentioned by like kevin
leighton brown and air corvitz but it
was kind of synthesized in a theoretical
work by
tim and rishi
so first you fix some parameterized
algorithm or mechanism in economic
context
like say an integer programming solver
and then you receive a set of typical
inputs samples from some unknown
application specific distribution
over uh problem instances so for example
this could be a distribution of where
all of the sequence alignment problems
that a dna or that of like biolab solves
solves day after day so each element of
this like training set or set of typical
influence in the context of sequence
alignment for example would be a pair of
sequences and perhaps these typical
inputs are labeled by some ground truth
reference solution though that's not
necessary even like the broadest
sense of this model
then you perform some optimizations and
you return a parameter setting row hat
which has good average empirical
performance
over your training set
and performance can mean a lot of
different things for example maybe
you're trying to optimize runtime maybe
you're trying to optimize the quality of
the solutions you're producing and so on
and so there are a few key questions we
need to answer about this very high
level procedure
the first is how do we find a parameter
setting which has good average empirical
performance
over our set of typical inputs are a
training set
and this algorithmic question has been
studied pretty extensively from the
applied perspective
over the past like 15 years or longer
um
and so there exists like tons of
different algorithms you could use for
doing this actual optimization procedure
the focus um the question i'm going to
focus on in this section is more of like
a
statistical nature
which is no matter what algorithm you
use to optimize your parameters using
your favorite black box parameter
optimization algorithm
can you guarantee that whatever
parameter setting you came up with
however you came up with it that
parameter setting will also lead to good
future performances on problems from the
same application but which aren't
already in your training set
so for example in the context of
sequence alignment given a new pair of
sequences you don't know what the ground
truth reference alignment is
can you somehow guarantee that your
parameterized algorithm algorithm will
find an alignment which is close to that
unknown ground truth alignment
so a little more formally is the
expected performance of your parameter
setting also high it's you found a good
parameter setting over your training set
will it also be done in the future or an
expectation
so um
now i'll just give a quick overview of
the results in this section and then
i'll get more into the model and the
technical details
so again the key question we want to
answer in this section
is if i found a parameter setting which
has good average performance over my
training set will it also have good
future performance
and in this paper
we analyze this question for any
parameterized algorithm
where at a high level its performance
is a piecewise structured function
of its parameters so on any fixed input
performance is a piecewise structured
function
by which i mean it's piecewise constant
piecewise linear piecewise quadratic
piecewise uh something else so just to
give an illustration of this
you could um imagine we fixed an input
we're varying our parameters row one and
row two and we're looking at algorithm
performance so like runtime or solution
quality as a function of our parameters
on this fixed input in this picture it's
piecewise constant but it could be
piecewise linear or piecewise something
else
and i'm going to explain why this is the
case in a few slides but just to give an
example going back to that sequence
alignment
example we proved that the distance
between this dynamic programming
algorithm's output given a pair of
sequences s and s prime
and some arbitrary ground truth
alignment is a piecewise constant
function of those tunable parameters row
one row two row three and so on
but this piecewise structure is not
specific to sequence alignment we prove
that it unites a bunch of combinatorial
algorithm configuration problems ranging
from integer programming clustering
comp bio other problems in computational
biology beyond sequence alignment 3d
algorithms mechanism configuration
and others
and i'll also briefly mention there's
been a
line of research on online algorithm
configuration so this is where the
problem instances are not necessarily
coming from any fixed distribution
they may even be coming online
adversarially and um
in a fox paper and follow-up research uh
we showed that this kind of piecewise
structure in particular piecewise lip
search structure allows you to give no
regret learning algorithms for online
algorithm configuration
and one more thing i'll note is this
line of research on mechanism
configuration ties into a really long
line of research on machine learning
format revenue maximization that i'm not
going to get into in this talk
so now before i get to a bit more
formally the model and
our results i i want to point out what's
the key challenge that we face in
providing these types of statistical
guarantees
and it's really that algorithms
performance
in these combinatorial domains is just a
very volatile function
of its parameters
so you could imagine returning some
parameters along the horizontal axis
we're measuring performance like runtime
or solution quality along the y-axis and
these performance functions are just
very volatile with many jump
discontinuities
intuitively this is because in these
combinatorial domains if you just tweak
an algorithm's parameters by a little
bit you can cause a cascade of changes
in the algorithm's behavior
and this causes these sharp jumps in the
algorithm's performance like it's run
time or
so on
so overall there's just a very complex
connection between an algorithm's
parameters
and its performance on any given input
meanwhile for those functions that we
really understand well from a
theoretical perspective in machine
learning
there's typically a fairly
straightforward connection between a
function's parameters and its value on
any given input
it says we don't have this really
predictable structure in the context of
combinatorial algorithm design we have
to understand what structure is there
which will allow us to provide these
types of provable guarantees
okay so now i'm going to get a bit more
into the model and our problem
formulation
so in our model let's say that rd is the
set of all parameter settings
and x is going to be the set of all
algorithm inputs
so for example let's return to the
sequence alignment example there are
three tunable parameters uh
so the set of
parameter settings is r3
and x would be a set of sequence pairs
so one element of the set x would be
like a pair of sequences it's the inputs
to our algorithm
so a little more formally what do i mean
by algorithmic performance
i'm going to use the notation u row of x
to denote the utility of the algorithm
parameters by row
on the input x
so again this could be like runtime
solution quality distance some ground
true solution
and and so on so for example in the
context of sequence alignment url of x
would be the distance between the
algorithm's output and some ground truth
solution
and as i alluded to earlier
we're going to make this standard
assumption that has been made for
many years in this algorithm
configuration community which is that
there's some unknown application
specific distribution over inputs to our
algorithm
so this is meant to model the
application domain at hand
so for example
perhaps this is a distribution over
pairs of dna strands that this bio lab
has to align from distributions of
repairs of protein sequences of some
animal or something like that
and now with this notation uh i'll tell
you like what is the key question we're
trying to answer which is we want to
know for any parameter setting rho
can we guarantee that average empirical
utility over the training set will be
close to its expected utility
so um more formally given samples x1 up
their xn so these are all problem
instances drawn from a are under unknown
distribution
we want to know for any parameter
setting
what's the difference between that
parameter settings average empirical
utility or performance over the training
set
and its expected utility on our
distribution
and i'll just emphasize that like if
this difference is small for any choice
of the parameters then you can be
certain that so long as you found a
parameter setting with good average
empirical utility over training set it
will also have good expected or future
utility
okay and now i um i i said that in the
beginning that
our
guarantees apply to algorithm families
where performance is a psi structured
function so let me give you an example
of this
and first let me just remind you what
the sequence alignment algorithm looks
like
so we're looking at this standard
algorithm from sequence alignment
defined by these parameters row one row
two row three
and uh this algorithm returns the
alignment which maximizes number of
matches minus row one times number of
mismatches minus row two nine times the
number of index minus row three times
the number of gas
okay and now to prove that this uh
piecewise structure holds i'm going to
tell you about this lemma uh proved by
gus hilt at all in a very different
context but which turned out to be
really useful for us
which says the following
for any pair of sequences s and s prime
so for example maybe that pair sequence
is there
let's feel that all proved that there's
a small partition of r3
defined by like if n is the length of
these sequences defined by like n to the
three halves hyperplanes so there's a
small partition of r3
such that in any one region
the algorithm's output so the sequence
alignment outputs is fixed across all
parameter settings in that region so
this is saying like for example if you
look at this region here
no matter what parameter setting you use
in this region you're always going to
get this particular alignment
and if you move to like another region
like this one no matter what perimeter
setting you use you're always going to
get that alignment
and this immediately
implies that algorithms utility is a
piecewise structured function or
piecewise constant function of these
parameters using the exact same
partition from the previous slide and
remember utility is the distance between
the algorithm's output
and some ground truth reference
alignment
yeah
yeah so um
i'll be a bit more specific about this
later but basically our guarantees hold
if for any pair of sequences say us any
pair of sequences s and s prime this
structure holds so this is like fix a
pair of sequences sns prime
uh utility is a piecewise constant
function of the parameters and this kind
of structure it can be a different
partition but this structure has to hold
for every pair of
that's three sequences r3
uh what is three
uh it's three is the number of
parameters
okay so it's it's
yeah
in this picture i'm just showing two
parameters just for the sake of the
picture but there would be three
parameters
oh yep can you also have destroying
regions that output have to have the
same output for a fixed sequence curve
yeah yeah you can have disjoint regions
um i'm not sure actually in this
particular example like if there are
disjoint reasons that i'll put the same
parameter setting but in general you it
would be fine for that
okay so now um with this
example in mind let's think of i'm going
to define piece by structured functions
more formally
and let's remember this notation that i
introduced earlier on url of x the
utility of the algorithm parameters by
row on the input x
and okay so if i collect the set of all
such functions u rho i'm going to denote
it u and i'm going to refer to it as a
primal function class
and typically in learning theory we
prove these types of generalization
statistical guarantees by understanding
what is the intrinsic complexity of this
primal function class u using tools that
you might have heard of before like
these two dimensions pseudo-dimension
and radomacher complexity and so on
but the challenge in this algorithm
combinatorial algorithm configuration
scenarios is that this function class
this primal function class u is pretty
gnarly so for example in sequence
alignment
every domain element so every element of
the set x
is a pair of sequences
uh so it's not clear how to plot or even
visualize these functions you row
which take as input the problem instance
and are defined by these tunable
and there are no obvious notions of
lipschitz continuity or smoothness we
can rely on because like this set x is
like a set of sequence pairs
so this is where transitioning to the
dual function class uh really comes in
handy
so rather than fix the parameters row
and vary the input x i could just as
well fix the input x
and vary the parameters row and i'd get
utility on a fixed input as a function
of these parameters
and uh naturally ux of rho equals 0 of x
we're just changing what we're varying
and if i collect the set of all such
functions ux
i'll denote it use star
and i'll refer to it as the primal our
dual function class
and what's really nice about these dual
functions is that they have this in
algorithm configuration they have these
simple euclidean domain
rd the set of all parameters whereas the
primal functions the domain of these
functions was like this combinatorial
object
and they often have this ample structure
that we can use to bound the intrinsic
complexity of the class that we actually
care about
you the primal function class
and so what i've been alluding to
throughout this talk is that across all
of these different settings so we saw
this was true in computational biology
that these dual functions fix the input
vary the parameters that was a piecewise
constant function and then across a lot
of different domains these dual
functions are also piecewise structured
in some sense clustering integer
programming mechanism design greedy
algorithms voting mechanisms
we see like piecewise inverse quadratic
functions the boundaries between
functions may be like polynomials but
they're all piecewise structured
and now um
now let me tell you at least the like
flavor of the main theorem in this paper
and to do so i'll just have one quick
slide a little more about what i mean by
intrinsic complexity in the context of
learning theory so what is like the
intrinsic complexity of a function class
g
so intuitively these measures of
intrinsic complexity are meant to tell
us
how well new functions in this class fit
complex patterns so for example these
like sine functions would be more
complex than the set of all like
constant functions because you can fit
more complex patterns using sine
functions than
like constant functions
and we have a lot of specific ways to
quantify intrinsic complexity which i'm
not really uh gonna get into here uh the
definitions but you might have seen them
before like vc dimension and
pseudo-dimension
so now the main theorem
uh and i'm going to start with a picture
so let's say that we've got um in this
picture two tunable parameters but we
could have any number of tunable
parameters which is for the sake of
picture there are two tunable parameters
r1 and root two and we're plotting some
dual functions so fix the input x vary
the parameters row and again this is
like in economic context it would be
like revenue
otherwise it could be like runtime
solution quality etc
and let's say that for any input x so
like any pair of sequences there are
these functions f from some set f
which
partition the parameter space into
region so in this picture there would be
three functions partitioning the
parameter space into six different
regions
such that in any one region
this dual function is equal to some
function g
from sunset g
so like in this picture g would be the
set of all constant functions but it
could be any set of functions
so let's say that this structure holds
for any
uh problem instance
we prove that with high probability for
any choice of the parameters row the
difference between the average empirical
utility over the training set and
expected utility is bounded by h h is an
upper bound on utility or performance
over the support of our distribution
times the square root of this pseudo
dimension of the dual of the set of
piece functions plus the vc dimension of
the dual of the set of boundary
functions and
again you can think of these as just
measures of the intrinsic complexity of
those sets of functions
times log k where k is the number of
boundary functions
creating this piecewise partition so in
this picture k would be 3
um divided by n where n is the size of
our trainings
and um for those of you who have seen
learning theory before i'm just going to
give a one slide proof sketch of this
theorem
so first um
there's a thing that we do to pray this
theorem is fix some set s
of inputs so like uh sequence pairs
each input in s is going to define k
boundary function splitting up the
parameter space
leading to a total of sides of s times k
boundaries and the first thing we're
going to do is count the number of
regions induced by all of these sides of
k sides of s times k boundaries and
interestingly this depends not on the vc
dimension of the primal of the set of
boundary functions but rather the vc
dimension of the dual of the set of
boundary functions
so in each region defined by these sides
of f sense k boundaries
these dual functions are all
simultaneously structured
they're all they're all constant or
they're all linear or whatever g is
and we now count the number of
parameters in each region
that lead to significantly different
algorithmic performance and this depends
on the pseudo dimension of the dual of
the set of piece functions
and finally we aggregate all of these
bounds over all of the regions to get
that the pseudo dimension of the primal
function class is bounded by the
pseudo-dimension of the dual set of
pieces these functions plus the vc
dimension of the dual the set of
boundaries tim's log k and this implies
our our main theorem
okay um so now i'll
bounce back to sequence alignment and
describe how this main theorem applies
guarantees for sequence alignment
let's remember that lemma which is at a
high level that um in sequence alignment
the algorithm's utility so distance to
ground truth is a piecewise constant
function of the parameters and if we
just plug everything we know
into
that main theorem we get that a training
size set of size log the maximum length
of these sequences divided by epsilon
squared will imply that with high
probability for any choice of the
parameters average utility of the
training set is epsilon close to
expected utility
okay um and now i just want to give a
one slight overview of a related problem
i talked about but i just wanted to say
a little more about
which is online algorithm configuration
so here we look at the problem where the
inputs are not coming in id from some
unknown distribution but they're coming
in online they may even be coming in
adversarially so for example let's think
about like the contents of clustering
the way this works is on day one you
choose some parameter setting for your
clustering algorithm or whatever
algorithm it is
and you plus you get a clustering
instance maybe adversarially you cluster
it using row one like you see how well
you did and on the next day you update
your parameter setting row two
you click you got a new clustering
instance you see how well you did and so
on
and um as is typical in online learning
the goal is to compete with the best
parameter setting in hindsight and a no
regret sense
and what's kind of interesting in this
online algorithm configuration scenario
is it that this goal is actually
impossible in the worst case
um
you cannot get a no regret algorithm in
the worst case your regret will go
linearly with the number of rounds
um so the
this line of work studies under what
conditions is online algorithm
configuration possible can you get a no
regret algorithm
and um one example is like when the
these
dual functions are again piecewise
structured but the adversary can't
concentrate the boundaries into too
small a region because that's when the
adversary can get um really adversarial
is when they can concentrate these
boundaries arbitrarily close so i missed
the online setting so did that so yes
thanks
yeah so the in the online setting
um
the way it works you've got your
parameterized algorithm say like in this
example would be a parameterized
clustering algorithm
on day one you choose a parameter
setting you get a clustering instance
and you cluster it see how well you did
um update your parameter setting see how
well you did and so on and yeah it's
impossible in the worst case but under
some kind of like smoothness assumptions
you can prove no regret out um yeah why
is it in the worst case
yeah so um there's like a classic
example in online learning of um
uh of the adversary who can give like
linear regret in the time scale which is
uh learning
uh thresholds
so um
basically like you choose a point and
the adversary is like nope you are
totally wrong the threshold is goes in
the opposite direction then you choose
another point the adversary is like nope
you did you were totally wrong uh the
threshold goes in the opposite direction
and so they can like choose these
thresholds in such a way that there
exists a point that did perfectly in
terms of the thresholds but you did
terribly and you can kind of embed this
problem into the context of algorithm
configuration
okay so that's what i wanted to say
about algorithm configuration
um really i've got like an hour of time
so i i the plenty of pending take
questions sorry i like i'm usually used
to discrete setting but let's say if i
want my parameters to be bounded using n
bits
if my instance of size m
then these issues would go away or would
you then say that like
if i'm very unstable in the position it
would not make a good parameter how
would you yeah
yeah i think so that that worst case
example of
of learning thresholds to get a linear
regret which we embedded to get the no
uh the lower bound for lower bound um i
think that would require the adversary
to have like infinite precision so with
respect to generalization then i would
have only like
many parameters so yeah yeah yeah so in
general in learning theory like
uh
in general in learning theory like if
you're describe your hypothesis class
with like a bounded number of bits then
yeah you only really need like the
number of bits divided by
epsilon squared samples to learn
um
yeah so that's like a general phenomenon
um earlier you had a bound that was
related to if you in your training data
saw sequences of a certain length
um i guess how often do you know what
features of your input are relevant to
determining how much your sort of ideal
parameters are going to fluctuate
um
sorry can you repeat that question like
um
it seemed like the sequence length
you choose your parameters and if you've
seen sufficient sequences in the past at
a certain length that you'll do well on
the similar
sort of input in the future right yeah
um
in these situations do you usually know
what kinds of features of the input
itself are
relevant so you can say oh this input is
very different from what i've
historically seen
um
yeah i guess
that's kind of related to ideas um
algorithm portfolios so this i don't
there hasn't been as much theoretical
research on this but there's been a lot
of applied research
where um
basically the way it works is like in
what i described you're just learning a
single configuration that you're hoping
or proving that it will do well in
expectation
but
you could imagine also you compile like
a diverse set of k different parameter
settings and you also learn a function
that tells you given the at runtime i've
got this input
and given features of this input which
algorithm in my portfolio
should i use
and um and so then if like say on half
of your instance you know in your
example like say on half of your
instances
the
like the configurations that do well are
totally disjoint or something that could
help uh
still do well in general like if you
could learn uh uh algorithm selector
is that kind of dance move yeah thank
you
okay um cool so now i'm going to move on
to algorithms with predictions
and um i'm primarily going to talk um
i guess about a paper that connects
really well to on a pump section of the
talk
um on ski rental
by pro hit it all
and i also um refer anyone who's
interested in this to this book chapter
by mittenmaker and vassilvitsky same
book chap the same book as
nina's chapter which i referred to
earlier um it's like uh the book on uh
beyond worst case analysis by tim ruff
garden
[Music]
okay so um how are those two predictions
so um this is like another way of using
machine learning in the context of
algorithm design which i think has some
connections to what i was describing in
the first part of the talk um but like a
different take
so in this in this problem you assume
that you have some kind of like
predictions about what your problem is
going to look like based on like your
historical uh
your historical like experience with
solving these types of problems so just
to give an example
maybe these predictions tell you the
probability that any given element is an
element of some huge database
or in the context of caching
this um
prediction might tell you the next time
you're gonna see
an element
uh so you so you ha you're looking at a
particular element you're trying to
decide which what to evict from the
cache and then caching this prediction
would tell you what's when when am i
going to see this element again
and the main question in this line of
research on algorithms with predictions
is how should i use these predictions
now to improve the performance of my
algorithm
i'm going to start off
with two examples and then i'll describe
kind of more generally the design
principles and approaching these
this line of research
so the first example will be searching
an assorted array
so in this problem you've got a assorted
array you don't know like
um
you have a certain array and you want to
figure out given a particular query q
you want to find q's index in this array
um if q is in if q is actually in the
array another wise output like a fail if
q isn't in there right
of course you can do this in like log
the size of the array but we want to see
if we can do it faster using predictions
and in particular what the predictions
we're going to be using are
is also known as hfq and it's a
prediction
of q's index in the array so you can
imagine this is like some huge array
um but if it's maybe sorted
alphabetically and you know that you're
looking for
like
the data of some person whose last name
starts with a
it doesn't make sense to start your
binary search like right in the middle
of the array it makes more sense to
start it kind of at the beginning
okay and with this predictor we've got a
pretty natural algorithm
so you've got your guess h of q and the
first thing you do is check if at the
array in the array at index h of q if q
is in that
in in that index
and if it is you return that index
otherwise
um if if your query is larger than
whatever is contained in that hfq index
you check what's in a at index h of q
plus two then h of q plus four then h of
q plus eight and so on
um until you find a element that is
actually larger than what you're
searching for
and let's say it's like at l index h of
q plus 2 to the i for some i
now you do binary search on the interval
h of q plus 2 to the minus i to h of q
plus 2 to the i and you're guaranteed
that if q is in the array then it's
going to be
in that interval
and you do like basically the symmetric
thing if if q is smaller than whatever
is in the index uh h of q
um
[Music]
and just to give an example let's say q
is eight h of q is two uh first you
check what's in two it's three so it's
smaller so now i'm going to check what's
in index four
still smaller what's in index
six
uh now i found something larger so now i
can do binary search over a really small
interval which is just like a single
element and i found what i'm looking for
okay and the analysis is really
straightforward as well so let's say
that t of q is the true index of a of q
and a or like the closest element if q
is in an a
so the runtime of this algorithm is
going to be log of the difference
between t of q and h of q's t of q is
the true index h of q is your predicted
index so you can think of this as like
the projection error
and why is this so
finding the
like when we were doing this kind of
progressively larger search for the
largest or smallest element um larger a
smaller element that takes log the t of
q minus h of q steps
and then binary search within that
interval also just takes log t of q
minus h of q steps so in total the
search takes log d of q minus h of these
steps
so the takeaway is that better
predictions will lead to better runtimes
um so like if you predict perfectly each
time you'll always just find the element
immediately
but your runtime is never worse than the
worst case of log the size of a red the
array so even if your predictions are
absolutely terrible you're never going
to do
worse than the worst case
okay um now i'm gonna
give a bit of a more nuanced example now
which is the ski rental problem and this
will look familiar to probably most of
you who are here for any palms part of
the talk but just in case there's anyone
new i'll just go over it super quickly
in one slide
so the problem here is we've got a skier
who's gonna ski for some unknown number
of days
and this skier has a choice they can
either rent for each day uh for one
dollars a day or they can buy for b
dollars so for example like if they ski
for five days they discover they really
like skiing um so they buy the skis the
total they're going to pay is five
dollars for each day plus b dollars when
they buy
and so if you ski for x days if the x is
like the true number of days that you
stood for the optimal clairvoyant
algorithm which knows what x is is we'll
just
pay
to rent every day if x is smaller than b
or it will pay the price of b at the
very beginning if it knows that x is
larger than b
so they pay a optimal price of min of x
and y
okay and then anupam had talked about
this like break even strategy
which is where
you so you don't know x this is your
strategy with you when you don't know x
you rent for b minus 1 days and if
you're still interested in skiing you
buy
and we went over the competitive ratio
for this and remember competitive ratio
is like the price that the algorithm
pays divided by the price that the
optimal algorithm pays the clairvoyant
strategy phase
so the algorithm is going to pay x
dollars if x is smaller than b it's also
it's just going to rent up until the
time steps and then we said on the beef
day
they're going to buy if they're still
skiing so they're going to end up paying
a total of b minus 1 for all of the days
they rented plus b
for the time that they bought
um
and
so this if you look at it is going to be
smaller than two and as we saw this is
the best deterministic strategy
we also saw that uh carlin adele
provided a randomized algorithm with a
competitive ratio of e over e minus one
okay so how do we um incorporate
predictions
into this problem
so let's say that you have a prediction
y
of the number of days you're going to
see
so your area eta is the difference
between x and y
so like the first algorithm you might
try to incorporate
predictions into this problem is to buy
at the very beginning of time
if you predict you're really going to
like skiing so you think i'm really
going to like skiing i'm just going to
buy
um and otherwise you're just going to
rent all
every single day that you ski you're
never going to buy
but a simple case analysis
shows that this algorithm the price of
this algorithm pays is at most opt
um the optimal algorithm would pay plus
eta
and the problem is that uh this means
that the computer
competitive ratio can be like unbounded
so for example if you predict that
you're not going to like skiing so you
predict y a small
but it turns out you love skiing
x is much much larger than b
you end up paying a lot because you just
rented every single day but the optimal
strategy would have just fought at the
very beginning so you'd end up doing
like really terribly
okay so what's a like smarter way of
of incorporating these predictions into
an algorithm so this is a algorithm
defined by a tunable perimeter lambda
between zero and one and we'll discuss
big tradeoffs in setting lambda closer
to zero positive
and
one
algorithm is also really simple
so
if you predict that you really like are
you going to really like skiing
you you don't buy right away but you do
buy on the start of day
lambda
otherwise you buy on the start of day be
over lambda so otherwise you you just
freaking you're probably not gonna like
skiing but you don't rent forever you do
buy eventually
and uh the way that i interpreted this
is like
if you predict you're really gonna like
skiing like don't jump the gun and buy
the skis like right away dude like test
it out and see if you like skiing um
before you buy but also don't wait too
long like if you predict you are not
going to like skiing but it turns out
you kind of do don't wait too long to
buy
and so this algorithm has a competitive
ratio that's bounded by the minimum of
one plus lambda over lambda
plus one plus lambda lambda is our
perimeter
um plus eta eta is our error divided by
one minus length times soft
so now interpreting this competitive
ratio of it if your predictor is perfect
so ada is zero you know exactly how much
you're gonna like skiing
um the competitive ratio is pretty small
so it's like at most uh one plus lambda
because this is zero and we're taking
them in
um so if like the uh interpretation is
if you think if you trust your predictor
a lot you think that ada is probably
going to be small
you might think about choosing lambda
also to be small and you are if like you
choose lambda to be zero
and eta is actually zero you're going to
be doing as well as the like
clairvoyance strategy
um otherwise like even if your predictor
isn't very good no matter how big ada is
uh if you said lambda to be one
then um the min is going to be like less
than or equal to one plus one over one a
two so you're going to recover that
baseline deterministic competitive ratio
of two
um and let me just give you like a brief
idea of how we prove uh or how
prohibited i'll prove this theorem and
i'm just gonna focus on this first term
and like the proof sketch so how do we
prove competitive ratios one percent
over atlanta
uh let's just think to start off with
the case where your prediction is much
much larger than b
so uh from the previous slide this means
that the algorithm will buy on the start
of the lambda b
okay so competitive ratio algorithms
payment divided by the optimal payment
let's think about the case where the
true number of days you ski
is at most lambda b
so lambda b is smaller than b because
lambda is smaller than one
so um
that means that your algorithm is gonna
uh rent every single day up until day x
and then it's gonna stop scheme uh
similarly the optimal clairvoyance
strategy will also
um just rent every day so you get a
competitive ratio of one in that case
now let's think about the case where x
is between lambda b and b
in this case
the your algorithm is going to tell you
to
buy on the start of day lambda b you're
still skiing on daylimbi
so you're going to pay a rent your
rental price
up until like lambda b minus one day
then you're gonna buy pay b
but x is still smaller than b so the
clairvoyant strategy will just still
rent every day
and finally last case x is smaller than
b i mean sorry x is larger than b so in
this case still like you're still buying
um using
the uh algorithm and the optimal
strategy just buys at the start of baby
or start of day one
and if you look at this uh case-by-case
thing you'll see that this is worst when
x is equal to lambda b and this is kind
of like when um the algorithm is telling
you to do something as different as
possible from what the optimal strategy
would do like you're you're buying but
the algorithm you're buying but the
optimal strategy would still rent
and in this case like if you just kind
of cancel out the b's uh this
uh is less than or equal to one plus
lambda over lambda
and you can do like the same analysis
for when your prediction is smaller than
the um b
and
kind of a similar like case but a bit
more involved case by case analysis
handles like the second term there
okay um so
we've kept seeing uh a few kind of
design principles pop up
in these two examples so let me just
um formalize them a little bit
and i think um it was the paper by
fedoris and sergey vasiletsky that first
like
gave one of the first like papers on
this kind of using machine learning
predictions in the context of algorithm
design and also formalize these two like
desert errata
okay so um
first
thing we want these algorithms to
satisfy is consistency
which says that if my predictions are
perfect
ideally i should just recover the
offline optimal algorithm
and a bit more firmly we say that an
algorithm is alpha consistent if the
competitive ratio approaches alpha as
the error approaches zero
we also want a robustness which is that
this handles the case if the predictions
are perfect what about the case where
the predictions are terrible we still
don't want our algorithm like to like
totally fail
so robustness says that if the
predictions are terrible
my algorithm shouldn't do worse than the
worst case
so a bit more firmly an algorithm is
beta consistent if the competitive ratio
is at most beta
no matter what your error data is
so looking back at the ski rental
problem where they each proved that the
competitive ratio was bounded by this
quantity we see that um
this algorithm is one plus data
consistent because as the error goes to
zero
um the competitive ratio will be bounded
by one plus eta
and it's also one plus eight over eta
robust because we're now the competitive
ratio is never worse than one plus eight
over eta
sorry lambda
and it turns out that these bounds are
tight so like for any one plus lambda
consistent algorithm um it's going to be
at least one plus slammed over linda
robust
and i'll just um briefly mention that uh
prohibited i'll
also give a randomized algorithm which
is like lambda over one minus e to the n
minus lambda consistent and one over one
minus e to the lambda minus
one over b robust and um
it's not obviously me but like if you
plot these this is better than that one
and these are also tight these
randomized bonds are also taken
um this has really just scratched the
surface
um on learning with predictions and
there's been like a ton of research in
many different areas on this problem
from online advertising stretching
actually back so you see similar ideas
to that stretching back um even to 2007
um caching frequency estimation learning
approximation scheduling matching
queueing covering problems many other
problems and you can see this github
page algorithms with
predictions.github.io
for like a pretty good aggregation of
all the different problems that have
been looked at from this perspective
question yes yeah yeah any questions
yeah you sort of treat the prediction as
some sort of a worse gift
where the prediction is some sort of
from a description
yeah
um
so
um
yeah so yeah i was giving this as a kind
of worst case example but there have
been also papers that say
um
the predict the expected prediction
error is bounded by ada
and um and things still work out in that
case does that kind of yeah yeah yeah
sort of have some distribution on
predictions but yeah maybe the mode is
the truth
yeah exactly so this is almost like a
with probability one prediction is
founded by
um ada but yeah there have been lots of
papers that look at in expectation it's
founded by the
any other questions
um in the last i just have like maybe
one more example but it's very short and
hopefully like fun so um the last
example of the day which is learning how
to prune um
uh
prune
um unimportant parts of the search space
this is my last example i think it's
like 10 minutes and then i'll move to
conclusions in future directions
and this is from a paper um with daniel
olafi who's here um adam kalai katrina
legit kim let's go chris
from cold 19.
um and to motivate these results i'll
tell you about um growing up in this
beautiful town called lincoln and so
when i was growing up in lincoln we used
to go to this nearby city called
burlington all the time
and there were a couple of different
routes that we might take between
lincoln and burlington
um because traffic would vary daily but
there were only a couple of routes that
we would ever take
but there was a bunch of like dirt
muddy roads that did connect lincoln and
burlington but um which was new would
like never ever be on the shortest path
between lincoln and burlington
however worst case algorithms like
dexter's algorithm would waste time
searching these muddier roads that we we
as humans knew would just never be on
the shortest path between these two two
towns
so the goal and this motivates the
overall goal in this paper which is to
quickly solve sequences of similar
problems
like say the problems that a commuter
would face driving to work every day
well exploiting common substructures to
like solve these problems faster and
then the worst case
algorithm would solve them
and the insight is that there are often
large swaths of the search space that
simply never ever contain the optimal
solution and our goal is going to be to
learn to ignore them so we saw an
example where that was the case in
routing we knew that like the optimal
solution would never go along those
certain roads but um
this is also true in the context of like
linear programming where there's
typically only a handful of constraints
that ever actually bind
as well as
say string search where there's
large portions of dna strings let's say
that like never will contain patterns of
interest
so a bit more generally our model in
this paper is that there's some function
f that maps problem instances
in x to solutions i'll call them y
and the learning algorithm is going to
receive a sequence of inputs x1 x2 of
their xt
and so for example each xi might
represent the edge weights on a fixed
road network varying day after day
and our goal is going to be to correctly
compute this function on most of the
rounds while minimizing the time we do
we take to do so
so um just to be clear the worst case
algorithm would just compute and return
this function f x i
um for each input x i in our model
okay but how do we hope to do this
faster well we're going to assume that
we have access to other functions
mapping x to y which are faster to
compute
and
defined by subsets or prunings s
of a universe mu
so
you know this universe u is meant to
represent the entire search space
and s is like a subset of the search
space
and we'll denote the
function we're computing corresponding
to the pruning s of the universe u as f
s
and the function that the worst case
algorithm would compute is just search
the entire search space which we denote
as f u
so for example maybe u is all the edges
in a fixed graph and s is a subset of
those sections so if we compute f u it
tells us the shortest path through the
whole graph and fs would tell us what's
the shortest path
contained within this subset of edges if
one exists
and one more thing about our model is
that we're going to assume that there
exists some set s star of x for every
input x which is like our minimally
proved subset
um specifically we require that f of s
of x so some pruning you look at some
pruning uh check out the function fs
evaluated on x will
equal the optimal solution if and only
if this minimally pruned set is a subset
of s
so for example in shortest paths the
minimally turned subset that needs to be
in your prune set in order to find the
optimal solution is simply the shortest
path
so now let me tell you about our
algorithm
first we initialized our prune set s1 to
be the empty set
and for each round j from one up through
t
first we receive our problem in since x
j
and with probability one over square
root of j we explore
which means that we just compute the
optimal solution f of x j
and we compute that minimally pruned
subset as star of xj so in this routine
example these would both just be the
shortest paths
and now we update our prune sets so sj
plus one will include we update to
include our minimally proven subset like
we update it to include the shortest
path
and otherwise we exploit which means we
just
compute the function f like contained
within our minimally pruned subset on
the input xj and we don't update our
print subset
so that's the algorithm
and so just to recap when i tell you
about our guarantees the basically at
each round j we
compute fsj for some sj sj is either the
entire universe or it's our prune subset
and this set sj depends on the what
we've seen on all the previous rounds
so our first goal is to minimize the
size of this prunes the size of the set
whatever set we're using to compute each
day we want to minimize the size of that
set because in our applications the time
it takes to compute these functions like
say shortest path grows with the size of
sj like the time it takes to search a
graph grows with the size of the graph
um and in particular we prove that if s
star is the union of all of our
minimally pruned subsets
so it's like say the union of all of the
shortest paths across all of the rounds
then in expectation over the randomness
of our algorithm the average size of the
set we're going to be
optimizing over is bounded by s star
plus this term
that goes to zero as t grows so
intuitively this is saying if there's
some similar structure among your
problems like the shortest passes and
changing that much round to round
then um
you're gonna be able to optimize your
runtime
but uh the second thing we want to do is
minimize the number of mistakes and
these are rounds where whatever you
computed does not match what the worst
case algorithm would have computed
and we proved that in expectation that x
the number of mistakes we make also
goes to zero as this um
as t
st grows
and we also
ran some experiments so this is a map of
pittsburgh and in this
these experiments the goal is to get
from the left
star to the right star
and so um these gray nodes are the nodes
that
they extrude algorithm or sorry a star
algorithm would have searched over the
course of like 30 rounds where the
network edges are changing each round a
little bit
um and the black nodes are the nodes in
our prune subgraph
so you see that you can see that we're
able to like
prune away a lot of the irrelevant edges
but we only make a
mistake like 0.06 fraction of the rounds
that's just one more like a fun example
of where machine learning could come up
in uh algorithm design
so now just conclusions and future
directions
so in this talk i described three
different ways machine learning has been
used in a theoretical context for
algorithm design including this
automated configuration
we saw that applied research on this
topic has dated back like two decades or
something and there's also been more
recent theoretical research on this
topic
i also described some of the research on
algorithms with predictions and then
this idea of learning to prove the
relevant regions of the search space
so um
now in terms of future directions
i think overall this is like a very
exciting direction um to be working and
because
because theoretical research on this
topic is really only just beginning
there's still many open directions with
the potential for both deep theoretical
analysis but also i believe significant
practical impact because i think in the
next like 10 years or so so we really
will see these machine learning
approaches to algorithm design
incorporated into large scale algorithms
say like integer programming solvers so
like at a commercial scale
so here are a few uh examples of future
directions that i think are especially
interesting
so the first one is um throughout this
whole talk uh i've really assumed that
you actually have enough data to learn
like you have years worth of scheduling
problems or you have a predictor that's
pretty finely tuned
but what if you're like just starting
out you're a shipping company just
starting out with like a singular
routing integer program
is it still possible that a software
like cplex could use machine learning to
speed up your performance to customize
the way it's solving your singular
routing integer program
so for example could similar problems
provide guidance maybe this company
itself doesn't have
a database of image of routing integer
programs but c plex solves like
thousands of routing integer programs
every single day so because duplex
somehow use this global database of
similar integer programs to customize
your performance on your like singular
imager program
but what does it like mean for integer
programs to be similar enough
that
uh configurations that worked well on
some
some subset of your training set will
work well on this new instance
another interesting direction is to
close the gap or close the loop between
classical algorithm design and analysis
and what i'll call data driven algorithm
design
so we've seen um
throughout all the sections of this talk
that classical algorithm design has
influenced data-driven algorithm design
because it suggested which algorithm
classes should i even try optimizing
over
but i think there are a lot of ways in
which data-driven algorithm design can
also influence classical algorithm
analysis
and for example if i understanding why
are some perhaps unexpected
configurations
so dominant
um
to give an example of this diode all in
a nerve 17 paper wrote that they so they
had an rl algorithm for solving various
combinatory optimization algorithms that
seem to do really well and they wrote
that their rl algorithm discovered what
they called new and interesting greedy
strategies for max cut and min vertex
cover
that were that intuitively made sense
but which had never been analyzed from a
theoretical perspective before
unless perhaps these like rl strategies
could be could provide a good assistive
tool
for
um discovering new algorithms
and this reminds me kind of of the
conversation um around like dolly and
other ais uh advances for people i've
looked at i've been looking at how can
like ai be an assistive tool ideally um
for say artists and i think it's
interesting to think of like ai as an
assistive tool even for theoreticians
it's so interesting like how were they
analyzed now these heuristics
yeah so for example that diet all paper
was like purely empirical
but i they say that like they're
um the greedy strategies we're still
interpretive as in like i don't quite
remember what it was but like say
um when like a vertex is connected to a
vertex and they have like similar
degrees or very different degrees or
something like that then you should add
this vertex or something like that so i
think um but like maybe theoreticians
have never looked at these particular
types of greedy strategies before so i
like the idea of it maybe giving like
theoreticians new way to brainstorm
about greedy strategies or any other
type of strategy
um and then the last direction which i i
personally find one of the most exciting
is
um
prior applied research has by diet all
in for example shipra and others has
shown that these machine learned
algorithms
can you like train on a small instance
but then they actually scale to
instances that are maybe like 10 times
larger or um or even larger than that
and
i think like the ideal goal would be to
eventually be able to train on small
instances and then use that machine
learned algorithm to solve instances
that no one has ever been able to solve
before like there are like integer
programming instances that have just
been opened for like decades no one's
ever been able to solve them you've seen
existing ip solvers and one of the big
challenges in using say machine learning
for integer programming is that getting
training data is super expensive because
you have to assault like say you're
training on similarly sized instances to
what you're then trying to solve
like training like getting a single
training uh data point will take really
long because you have to solve this
integer program so if you could like
solve if you could train on really small
instances and then uh use what you
learned to solve really big instances
that's that's really exciting
um and so i wonder if theory can provide
guidance about how and when
these types of algorithms are able to
generalize in terms of the scale of the
problems that they're solving so just to
give example maybe um this scale like
you're solving a problem over a graph
which is getting bigger and bigger and
bigger but it's still being like
generated from some fixed underlying
generative process can we somehow use
like theoretical analysis techniques to
understand like
how can i learn that algorithm that will
be able to train on these small
instances and then generalize to like a
huge instance
so with that i'll wrap up uh thank you
[Applause]
maybe for a quick question
the first part of the dog
yeah so like um yeah i guess not in the
context of algorithm configuration
per se though in
learning theory more generally like
um you you might prove uh generalization
bounds that are like specific to the
type of algorithm that you're using to
optimize the parameters and yeah so i
haven't seen those in the context of
algorithm configuration but um like say
it these bounds might depend on like the
stability of the algorithm you're using
for the optimization
so um
[Music]
yeah we didn't think about it kind of as
connected to the learning with
predictions but maybe you could um
and
yeah maybe there's a way i think um
yeah maybe there's a way to think about
it and provide other types of guarantees
about like learning to prune because i
think this is just one way of learning
to prune one type of guarantees you
could give but i think there are a lot
of different ways you can think about it
all right let's go again
[Applause]
so